So, you were asked by your chaplain to
contact your dead grandfather? I was
because I couldn't pray for him when he
was alive. So, to heal this, the
chaplain said, "Why don't you engage in
conversation in your mind with your
grandfather and see what he might have
to say to you today about that."
So, we're here today with Chris Lang and
Stephanie Griffith and they have an
amazing testimony from Stephanie and
Chris created an amazing documentary
called Mystified. It's coming out pretty
soon and so we're going to tell you all
about the story and how that came about
in uh in this episode. Can you tell us a
little bit about how that's going on and
then we're going to jump into your story
uh Stephanie. Absolutely. Thank you for
having us, Brad and Keith. It's a
blessing to be here on Little Light
Studios today with my friend Stephanie
Griffith.
Th- this is actually a celebration today
to be in the studio with Stephanie
because it it
for those who are seeking God and
seeking the truth um to have
behind-the-scenes things happen the way
they have
create an affirmation cuz there's very
few things in life you can prove.
You can't prove that your wife loves
you. You can't prove really very much of
anything but by evidence. You function
on evidence.
And there's plenty of evidence behind
the scenes that God was leading in the
making of this documentary and it
started with a phone call six almost six
years ago. Stephanie, why don't you tell
uh the audience what happened and how we
got connected. Okay. Well, I was at work
and
well, you returned the call when I was
at work but I had just finished my book
um about my testimony and building my
website and I remembered or stumbled on
a video that Chris had done Beware of
Angels.
And I thought, you know, maybe that's a
resource I can send people to from my
website. I was looking for resources to
send people to truth.
So,
we I touched base with him after many
years and
left a message and he called me back and
he's like, "Yes, so you can use my
website. What is your book about?"
And that was the beginning of a
conversation and a journey.
Yeah, and toward the end of the
conversation uh by the way, your your
audience uh
hopefully most of you by now have seen
Charmed by Darkness, which is the
amazing conversion story of a former
demon worshiper who became a Christian
author and prayer warrior named Roger
Morneau. Amazing story. Yes. So, the
reason I'm bringing this up right now is
one of these um praise God moments
behind the scenes that happened.
Stephanie and I are still on the phone
almost six years ago. I'm still working
on Charmed by Darkness even though
Beware of Angels just came out, which
was related to Roger's journey of
ministry after he came out of the
occult.
We're toward the end of the phone call
and Stephanie says, "Oh, by the way."
My husband knew Roger Morneau.
And he's like, "What?"
And so began another conversation.
She We were literally getting ready to
hang up. It was a phone call for her to
ask permission to use the link Beware of
Angels on her new book's website.
And at the end, "Oh, by the way."
And and so for a recap of of I I know it
a lot of people have already seen this
but who was Roger Morneau? Cuz he was a
significant um um
knowing his story is significant
probably to understanding what was going
on here. Yeah, it's it was a journey
that I started in 2014 with Roger's
family. Roger, as I mentioned, was a
demon worshiper who was part for a
period of months in Montreal, Canada
after World War II, was invited into a
secret society and he was offered gifts
and all kinds of secret knowledge that
is only available to people in the
Illuminati essentially who are at the
very top uh
I know you guys talk a lot about that on
Little Light to help people understand
that the God of this world, according to
2 Corinthians 4, the devil,
has his organization. It's hierarchical
and it's very organized.
And Roger had been invited into what is
called the Illuminati. It was the
a-
From all the research that I've done
over the years, I'm pretty certain the
level 33 Freemasons are the Illuminati.
There's not very many of them in the
world. There's only a couple hundred uh
33 Freemasons.
And they have the full light of the
spectrum. They're at the very top of the
pyramid.
At any rate,
Roger's given these gifts. He starts
getting dreams. He starts betting on
horses and he's winning a lot of money
and he actually has a a pre-initiation
service where he's brought in and he's
um
makes some vows before an altar
that was an altar to Lucifer, whom they
worshipped directly.
And they openly said that, too. Openly.
Openly and their teaching was very much
from the Bible. Their priest knew a lot
about the Bible but it was all turned in
a way that's that was
gentle and kind. Lucifer is the is the
benefactor of the human race. He was
misunderstood in heaven. He was thrown
to the earth and God is the bad guy.
Yeah. Sympathy for the devil.
And the only name they would give God is
they would refer to him as the creator.
Oh. They wouldn't say Jesus.
They wouldn't say any other name but
creator. Why?
Because they today don't exist
unless they're sustained like you and I
are right now and the viewers. All of
you are breathing right now by the will
of our creator.
And th- those fallen angels know
why they're alive today because he is
he is so loving and faithful but he's
also just and there will come an end.
And so Roger heard all of this and he
was uh he was he was he but he but he
was troubled. His parents warned him
when he was a child, "Don't play around
with evil because someday you will have
to pay the price." There was something
about this
th- what he was being taught that didn't
feel right.
And so one night he prayed a prayer that
bec- has become famous and we reenacted
it in our film Charmed by Darkness with
a young with a young actor who's playing
Roger's role. In the 1940s, he's laying
in bed at night and he cries out, "If
there's a God in heaven who cares for
me, help me."
And a few days later he met Cyril at at
the factory who ended up studying the
Bible with him and he came to know the
real Jesus and he came to understand
what the Bible really teaches about God
and he gave his life to the creator.
And he left that organization and for
the rest of his life
he testified to the deliverance that
happened in his life and he began to
pray biblical prayers and intercede for
people and he started writing books that
were all based on the miracles that
happened when he would pray for people.
And so it was Dondi, Stephanie's
husband, while Roger was alive, who was
going through a crisis and we reenacted
that in Charmed by Darkness.
And here's a young adult in the '90s
who's going through a life crisis and he
ends up driving finding one of Roger's
books after he's praying a desperate
prayer after he's a party animal
and he doesn't find any zest for life
anymore.
And he finds one of Roger's books on
prayer and he ends up driving 7 hours
without an appointment and he knocks on
Roger's door. He gets invited in
and Roger spends 5 hours with him that
first day in his living room teaching
him Yeah. about God, about all the great
things God had done for him.
And Dondi had hope for the first time
come over him and
the blessing for Roger, it wasn't just
Dondi's blessing but Roger was blessed
because you see later in the film
why Dondi's testimony
it's a miracle that Dondi's in the film
to start with because remember it
started with, "Oh, by the way."
My husband knew Roger.
And there was so much evidence like
pictures of him like you can see this
picture
um
d- of Dondi with Roger that you see in
the film and Dondi became the bridge
between what we're talking about today
and Roger's legacy. Huh. Because Dondi
learned what true biblical prayer looks
like.
And the whole film that Stephanie ended
up being a part of, the next film that's
called Mystified, is about exposing the
false prayer movement that is called
Christian. It's been Christianized but
it is a it is a pagan form
of trying to ascend to the gods through
altered states of consciousness.
But they don't call it that in the in
the Christian circle that's been
Christianized. They're very careful with
the words they use.
But Dondi became the bridge and it was
not something that any person could have
planned or coordinated
unless
someone was behind it all. Right.
Because Stephanie ended up marrying this
guy
while she was coming out of this
spiritual formation mystical movement.
Wow.
And they've a team in ministry today.
That's the end of the story that you
see.
And and you made a documentary about
this whole thing that's coming out
pretty soon, right?
Yeah. Would you like to see a trailer? I
would love to.
And then I would just take my deep
breath, say my word, my mantra, and go
into the silence.
My co-workers at the real estate
company, they said, "What is your
marketing strategy?"
I didn't have a marketing strategy. I
said, "I meditate. I get help from
spirits."
Friend of mine had something called
magic mushrooms. I don't know. I'd never
done them before and I said, "Let's try
it."
My mother, who was living in Sweden, she
died of cancer.
And he told me, "Vala, now I have found
something called ayahuasca."
The shaman asks every participant to say
their intention. What is it that you
want these spirits to help you with?
I asked for my mom
and Vala asked for the truth.
The truth about who I am.
The truth about why I'm here.
Elvis was a voracious reader.
Wherever he went
on tour,
two huge
trunks
were filled with his favorite books.
Near his body was a book called The
Scientific Search for the Face of Jesus.
What really was in that book?
Did Elvis find hope there?
We were asked by the Vatican to to get
involved in dialogue with Eastern
meditation and with Eastern monasticism
as the area in which Christianity had
the most common basis.
The fingers lead to the center of the
palm
and the various religions
and their deepest level lead to the
center of reality, where they are one.
Christ is not an individual. Christ is a
collective.
Most of us don't realize we are human
and divine at the same time.
You can't see God
because when you are God,
nothing to see.
But in practice, there's nothing to
believe. You just go and you know it to
be true for yourself.
We're not individuals.
When I questioned one of the instructors
about how she could venture into
Buddhism and still remain in the
Christian religion, she says, "I don't
really see a conflict."
Wow. So there's a lot in there that that
I question, is this even the correct
form of spiritualism? I mean, that I
think that's the that's the the
question, right? As you were going
through this, you're showing
what what in the world is actually
happening in these other forms of
spirituality that is different than what
we believe.
Right, exactly. And you know, today
we're focusing primarily on the
Christian
Christianized version of mysticism and
those who teach it in Christianity today
claim that it is biblical, that Jesus
was a mystic, that the apostles were
mystics, that Moses and Elijah were
mystics.
Wow. And so they overlay and they
twist the scripture to say to fit the
narrative.
But that's why in the in the trailer you
hear
these Roman Catholic voices saying Jesus
is not a or Christ is not a person. Mhm.
That's the one thing and you are truly
divine. You are human and divine at the
same time. Fully human and fully divine.
Mhm. So so this is this was something
when I heard Stephanie's story and
you're going to hear a full episode just
of her unpacking Mhm. her journey in
spiritual formation, which is the
Christianized curriculum of what you saw
in this trailer, just a little taste.
This is going to be over 2 hours long
when it comes out.
Because it's such a large universe of
compartmentalized
terminology that you saw in the graphic
of the guy talking about the five
fingers. The major religions, they all
lead to the center, to one truth. Mhm.
That's one world religion.
Yeah. That's mysticism,
spiritualism. You caught it. Mhm.
Because that's in essence, that's what
it is, but I had to do
over two We were talking last night when
we were kind of preparing for this
program and she asked me, "How long have
you been researching?
Or has this been going on since 2014
when you started working with the
Morneau family?" And it it has been kind
of a layered growth journey. But but but
in essence, it was full-time research
starting
uh in 2021 after the release of Charmed
by Darkness.
And um
so much research to go in to actually
listen to the words they're using.
You know, for us to make it to for us as
biblical Christians, some would call us
fundamentalist Christian, which is an
evil term these days, you know, if you
believe in absolute truth,
people say that, yeah. you you're they
use the word separation, that there's no
separation.
The thing I found after 2 years of
full-time research in this area,
the Christians who practice what she was
practicing
eventually end up in what is called
non-duality.
Non-duality.
This is what Buddhists talk about. They
understand it well. But Christians have
to be taught a version of non-duality
where there's still God, but you're
actually God, too.
That's non-duality.
panentheism
is God in all things.
Ah, okay. So there's a God, but he's but
his essence, see, big difference.
They'll use words in the Bible and and
apply the idea of divine nature being
God's essence, immortal essence.
That's where the deception comes in
because the Bible doesn't teach that.
And this is where immortality of the
soul comes in.
And spiritualism is the original lie at
the tree, right?
not surely die. And your eyes will be
opened. And it wasn't until a few months
ago that I saw that that original lie
is two part.
You won't die
because when you eat the fruit, second
part, your eyes will be awakened. You
will be enlightened. These are words we
hear
in the New Age and in Buddhism, right?
You've heard these words.
Your eyes will be opened. You'll be
awakened and you will be as gods.
Mhm.
And then this last part came clear,
knowing good and evil.
The Lucifer was saying to Eve, "Good and
evil coexist in the same reality."
That's non-duality.
That yin yang, the swirl with the white
and the black
Mhm. that are in a circle, the circle
stands for immortality.
And the light and the dark coexist
eternally. That was the essence of the
second part
at the tree. Isn't that something?
Wow.
Wow. Yeah, a lot of major religions go
back to the garden.
Not valid religions uh by Christian
standpoint, but a lot of major world
religions today.
What's interesting as I'm watching that
trailer, I'm thinking how there's this
this gathering together based on, you
know, we're all part of this this one
cohesive whole.
But what do you hear largely in society
today? No, no, no, whatever's good for
you is good for you and whatever's good
for me is good for me. It's totally the
opposite. This is like the the answer to
those who realize that doesn't work. The
the relativism doesn't work and so they
look for something else and well,
there's something there for you if you
if you want that, too. Devil's going to
get you either way. Mhm. There's real
power in it.
Um Stephanie, why don't you talk about
the benefits, so-called, that came from
the practice of what they call
contemplative prayer or contemplated
prayer. By the way, you'll hear me say
contemplative.
And that's not like what you would
expect, but all of the Roman Catholic
voices call it contemplative. So you'll
hear my voice-overs in the movie and
stuff, but
because I was like people were
challenging me. Contemplative, what is
That's not how do you say it? Like well
that's how they say it. Yeah. Anyway,
we're insiders now.
So when you were practicing
contemplative prayer,
what were the benefits? There was power
in it for you.
Yeah. Well, there's a dopamine effect
that I know now, but at first I thought
it was
I was literally in the presence of
Christ. Not that we were physically
there, but my intention, my mantra was
Jesus.
So I just I there was a time when I
looked at that and was taught that this
is like a very personal time. It's like
it's where sanctification happens.
It's like a very intimate
That's what they told you. Mhm. Dallas
Willard says it's it's the place where
sanctification occurs. Wow. So I was at
this point I had
um had my conversion experience after
some rocky roads and then
um but I had the history of not being
able to pray for my grandfather when I
was not in relationship with with God.
So
to come into what I thought was a more
deep relationship with Christ was a deep
desire for me.
And it had to do with prayer and I was
all about prayer. So I wanted that
intimate intimacy. I wanted a closeness.
And so I was told this is how
this is how it happens. Like I would
feel really I felt really sad for
all of you
who didn't practice contemplative prayer
because you were missing out on
something, right? So I felt bad for you
guys. It really is something
that only the initiated do, right?
um
But so what I experienced in those
moments was just um a peace. What I felt
was a very peaceful place and
um I don't know. It was just it was my
peaceful place and I thought I was
connected to Jesus.
So but it was interesting. I had a
roommate at the time.
And um if she would make a noise or come
in the room unexpectedly, I would be so
upset. I'd be like
well, what kind of fruit is that? Right?
That is not the fruit of
the right spirit. So there were telltale
signs
um along the way, but because of the
dopamine effect, it drives you to want
more.
So
in my um
in my two-year spiritual direction
program
I had to go. I didn't have to, but it
was part of the program to go on
spiritual retreats. So we had weekend
retreats and it was just a weekend of
silence.
Which I loved.
Plus they serve vegetarian food. Right
up my lane. So
By the way, maybe for the viewers that
don't know what silence means.
Silence. That means you empty your mind.
You empty your mind. It's not what you
would think the biblical idea of
silence, right? Get rid of your busyness
and listen to
pay attention to God and his word.
That's not what it really means. Yeah.
You're supposed to empty your mind and
get things out of the way. Like if a
grocery list pops up in your mind, you
just let it go. You don't hang on to it.
You don't get upset. You were thinking
about your grocery list cuz you're
hanging on, right?
You let go. And you just move everything
out of the way from your mind that gets
in the way between you and God.
Um so it's definitely not to meditate to
think on. Okay. Um yeah.
So that was it was just it drove me
more. I would I would do 12 hours and I
would want more, you know? So
um I thought that I was just really
becoming close to God. When you go into
this
the state where your mind just kind of
drives and it doesn't actually think
about things, then you get a sense of a
euphoria that makes you want to do it
over and over again. Is that is that
kind of what I'm seeing here?
Yeah, there's a dopamine release.
And it just feels good, right? Whatever
you do when when that dopamine to to
generate that dopamine, it just feels
good. For me it was peaceful.
It it just like got rid of all the chaos
on the outside.
We should be clear.
Stephanie
was being protected
while she was on a nine-year journey.
It's on after all of the research that
I've done over the last several years, I
can see God's hand has been on her life.
So that she could come out of this and
be a witness of what it is and how it
affects people's minds.
Because in the end it is about
possession.
Because
what you hear if you listen long enough
from these Christian so-called voices
and and by the way, Vatican II, the
Second Vatican Council in the '60s was
the launching pad
for
the Vatican's push to use the the
monastic orders of the day, the the
monks and nuns to promote this
mysticism.
Because it comes through their tradition
starting in the desert fathers in the
early centuries AD
who went out into the desert to practice
ascetic practices like fasting and they
would become emaciated and they would
end it up in in it all lead you to what
they believed would be a purified state
where their minds could receive and
connect with they called it union with
God actually. That's the Christianized
version of what Hindus call samadhi,
altered state, satori in Buddhism.
Altered state. Uh it contemplation is is
the pinnacle. Union with God is also
synonymous with contemplation. And they
and you're asking the question which is
a good one. What happens there? Yeah.
Yeah, what happens there? Because I mean
they're studying a different form of
spiritualism
that I've been trying to understand.
I've I've learned that
doing these
these uh
what do you call it when you like put
your hands out like this and you sit
back and
Like your mantras.
Yeah, mantras and enchanting and stuff
and you just kind of sit in you've it's
a form of self-hypnosis. Yeah,
self-hypnosis and communication almost
with these things.
It's an opening. Like you're creating a
portal. It's what's happening.
So what is what is the danger and I'm
saying this through a Christian view.
What is the danger in in walking around
here? What does it do
uh to your spiritual life? That and how
does it separate you or connect you with
the wrong For me
I it was just a way of I would enter in
with a question for God, right? And just
kind of just slow walk. It's a
contemplative exercise. Your mind goes
offline just like it does when you're
doing your meditations. Meditations.
That's what I was going to say. Yeah. So
when you're doing that
Which is by the way a misnomer also.
Yeah.
There's you're not really thinking about
anything.
It's called meditation. Your brain waves
waves flip from beta, which is what
we're in now, thinking, filtering,
judging
to alpha.
So when you take that frontal lobe
offline then we've just shut down the
Holy Spirit's mechanism of speaking with
us. That's where that's where we
experience conviction.
um And we're allowing them to
open to another spirit as Alice A.
Bailey says, you know, and and She says
that? You have some quotes that I don't
want to get into those. You can do
those, but that's that's like we're
shutting off to the Holy Spirit and
we're opening up
to
the demonic realm. Wow. When you hear
the term alpha this is a term which is
used very very frequently. That's their
way of saying I enter altered states and
there there will be quotes in the film
to confirm and clarify. These are all
words for the same place. They take a
person to the same place. What do you
mean witches and Christians and
Buddhists and Hindus all end up in the
circle in the center? Yeah, that's what
it that's what it is.
the same voice that's speaking to them.
This is important for the viewers to
understand. Stephanie has never believed
in the doctrine of the immortality of
the soul.
One of the things I wanted to research
because it seemed from the words that if
you listen long enough, it seems and I
mentioned before we started taping
today, the ancient Greeks used a term
the true philosophy is the practice of
dying before you die.
In other words, by entering into an
altered state, you can see what it's
like on the other side.
And therefore death is your friend. It's
not an enemy as the Bible teaches us.
So this So I wanted to find the evidence
that mysticism can't at any time be
called Christian.
It because it is not biblical at all and
I wanted to find the the rabbit trail
that went all the way back to find how
we could provide the evidence that it
doesn't come from the Bible at all.
And so there's a whole section in the
film that actually has a a dynamic
timeline that takes you all the way back
from the first uh book that she read
from Thomas Keating, one of the
post-Vatican II voices. I call them
post-Vatican II voices.
And by the way, there's a lot that are
not Roman Catholic that are promoting
this. As you know, there are Christian
Protestant Christians.
But you won't see me quoting them in
this film. Why?
Because if you listen to those guys long
enough, guess who they quote? Yeah,
other guys. They're Catholic mystics
that inspired them on their journey.
And they all believe that when you die,
you continue living. Correct. But the
practices, where did it come from and
how does it relate to the immortality of
the soul?
And God God showed me God gave me the
evidence that ties all the way back from
Thomas Keating in the 70s and the books
she was reading at the beginning of her
journey
all the way back to Mesopotamia and
ancient Babylon.
Um and through the ancient Greeks.
It didn't come through the early church.
It came directly from the ancient Greeks
into Christianity and there are quotes.
It's their words, not mine.
Their words admitting that Greek
philosophy
helped to illuminate the idea of what is
the soul and the afterlife and they
admit they got it from the Greeks. As
well as the practices of mysticism, the
monasticism that actually came out of
the desert, the desert fathers. You hear
that a lot.
But they were they were hermits and
nowhere in the Bible do you find the
disciples or Yes, Paul went to Arabia
after he was converted, but it was up
for a limited time. Like John the
Baptist was in the desert to be trained
by the Holy Spirit. Those are limited
uh chapters in someone's life. They
point at Jesus going into the wilderness
to be tempted by the devil and they they
point at that as evidence that he was a
mystic cuz he went out into the desert.
You see.
Um
and that's the that's the difficulty in
this is that people will use the Bible
and they openly admit that the mystical
practices we're talking about today
by going internally, you actually get a
deeper understanding of what the Bible
really means and so therefore
fundamentalism is an enemy.
The idea that the Bible actually means
what it says
if you really believe in the creation
story, you're a fundamentalist.
Wow. And they And that's a dirty word.
For for them it's a myth.
Because that's practices end up taking
you to evolution to to an impersonal God
that is penetrating and binding together
all in the universe. So it's God
everywhere. Yes, it's pantheism.
Yeah. But they still admit there's a
separate God somewhere in this equation,
but it's you see it's not consistent.
It's very confusing.
Fluid. Yes, whatever it takes to get you
to join them in the center.
That center where all the religions,
they have their separate dogmas and
practices, but in the center of this
practice you all come to understand that
everyone is divine.
And that good and evil don't
In other words, you don't differentiate
between gender. You don't This is where
we start to understand all the confusion
going on in society today.
Right in the center, there's no
differentiation.
I'm going to say that in my nine years
of doing this, I never heard the concept
that I am God
relating to
Christian mysticism.
Right. They're very careful in the way
They are. They're very very careful in
how they say these things and I never
heard new age terms.
But
I just saw just the other day the
Catechism has about three three places
in it where it says that you become
Christ.
Wow.
So they do teach that. But I would These
things were hidden from me
long enough for me to really get in and
absorb a lot of the stuff and then come
by the grace of God
expose it. Wow. People might wonder what
is the motivation behind all of this and
it's people who aren't reading their
Bibles and and through the Holy Spirit.
Again, it's not enough to read the
Bible.
We have to have the Holy Spirit.
Because you'll either receive the Holy
Spirit by the way, the one and only
is only provided through faith.
Right? In Jesus Christ. And they say
Christ is not a person.
If you listen long enough, that's what
Stephanie's saying. It was hidden from
her because the words and terminology
that they use are trying to entrap
Christians and once they get into the
practice, then their eyes are opened.
You see. And the more you meditate
you surrender
you connect to the divine and then you
become God.
I see this stuff now that I'm out and I
see these quotes, but I didn't see it
when I was in it. And honest people who
are really truly desiring to find God
like Stephanie
I want to tell the viewers, you know,
there are so many people Catholic and
Protestant and other worldviews that are
seeking desperately to find something
real.
And they're saying you can't find God
through your conscious mind.
You can't grasp him. You find it in
ancient books like The Cloud of
Unknowing which is which was the
inspiration from This is a medieval
author
who Thomas Keating and his group that
created what is called centering prayer
which Stephanie ended up practicing.
This book from the 1200 or 1500s
whenever the person wrote it, he's an
anonymous author
literally says you can't know God unless
you enter contemplation which is the
altered state.
And so that's the that's the
motivation for someone if you know, the
idea that you can find God through ideas
and dogma and law and all the It's the
same problem the Jews had, right? That
they were all about keeping the law and
trying to keep the Sabbath and all of
these traditions that were supposedly
working toward their salvation.
That no one can find it.
And so they're simply saying you can't
learn dogma and and your conscious mind
can't possibly grasp the infinite God.
And so you go into your altered state
which they call the true self. Your
false self, the Roman Catholics teach,
is your If you listen long enough, you
find out they're talking about your
conscious mind. Everything about
yourself they say is an illusion. That's
That's imported from Hinduism.
That your false self is an illusion and
the only immortal part of you is called
the true self. And you only find that if
you go and practice these things.
These things. So And then they use
biblical terminology. The death to your
false self, the resurrection
to life and awaken awakening
to find your true self which is union
with God in this altered state. It's
very gnostic. And and you can see how
this plays out in society in a lot of
ways. Catholic Church just by itself is
is very much that way. Like you can't
find the truth by yourself. You need
somebody to guide you and lead you
there, right? What do we you see the
same thing in pop culture, right? The
Matrix. Could Neo come to the
understanding by himself? No, no, no,
no. He needed Morpheus to guide him to
the truth, you know. He couldn't just
find it. He needed a guide, a mentor. I
wanted to go back to something you said
about the Greeks. I thought was
fascinating
about philosophy.
Um you can understand why the Greeks
would develop that type of philosophy
because if you're Greek
and you believe in this pantheon of
gods, what do you have to look forward
to you?
You know.
It's it's that that Greek version of
Hades that everybody looks to as the guy
with the pitchfork who is
you know, making sure you're being
rotated evenly so you're well done.
Who wants that, you know? And so for
them it's like it's like an escape
from that, right? Because who wants a
God like that? Who wants to serve a God
like that?
you brought up hell, Keith, because this
is a big reason why a lot of Christians
are leaving a fundamentalist concept of
scripture
because they can't conceive of a God who
would do that to human to human beings
who only live if you're lucky 80 years
and then and and there's unceasing
torture forever? And for good reason
because that God doesn't exist.
Exactly. Exactly. And so that's what
we're trying to show at the end of this
film in Mystified is is that the idea of
an unending torture is not biblical at
all.
So wait, what are you saying? Hell
doesn't exist?
Well,
they say that it doesn't. Hell is what I
bring to you. If I'm being mean to you,
then I'm bringing hell to you. It's on a
spectrum.
Yeah, according to how I treat you.
It's how I treat you.
mysticism.
you heaven or hell, there's no heaven or
hell. It's right here. This is the
kingdom. That's Hinduism.
Which is a philosophy
you also hear in Christianity a lot
right now. Kingdom now. Right? Now Now
let's get to the heart of where this
leads in the
you know, you were talking about the
pushback against this traditional belief
in unending torture. It's ended up being
that love is so great, God will save
everyone. Universalism.
Oh, universalism.
I kept I kept praying. I said, "God, why
are they pushing non-duality?" For
months I was praying to try to find the
the answer and God eventually led me to
non-duality is a form of pantheism,
right? If God is in in everything and
everything is one, that's non-duality.
No differentiation. No separation.
Everything is God.
That's a form of pantheism.
That means that you're immortal, you
can't die.
And that is where universalism comes out
of. This Christian term that people have
heard, it means that eventually everyone
will be saved. Why? Because God can't
kill himself.
You see, that's the that's the logical
conclusion of these terms and they seem
compartmentalized,
they seem different.
What's weird is it it almost comes back
full circle, right? Because if everyone
is God, then everyone can do no wrong
and so what does everybody do? They do
what's right in their own eyes.
Mhm. It's back to relativism again all
again.
And the question if that's true reality,
then the question is who makes the
rules? Mhm. And in the end
In the end You do. Well, in the end the
world needs needs a single authority.
Mhm. If everyone individually is is
experiencing their truth,
which is what this teaches you.
You see what I'm saying? Eventually you
have to have a one world order that
makes the rules.
And that's that's what people don't
realize. If God, the God that we serve,
doesn't exist, if everything is God,
then there's no escape. Mhm.
Because the universe itself is
humanistic. Mhm. The humans It's a bunch
of circular logic because, you know, if
I'm God and you're God and you're God
and you're God,
well, then,
you know, God makes the rules.
So, I you know, it's like I nobody has
to follow my rules because they're God.
So, God makes their own rules. That is
just It's a bunch of nonsense over and
over and over again just in this
continuous loop of nonsense and never
gets anywhere.
Well, and that's why it's humanistic
because at the end someone has to be the
police. In the end the greatest symbol,
I know we're running out of time, so I'm
trying to get to the last few comments
in regards to the the symbolism in all
of this is the ziggurat in Babylon.
The this
This isn't just a structure that most
Christians who study the Bible and they
learn about the Tower of Babel.
This is actually a symbol the of
ascending to an altered state of
consciousness.
The whole idea of going to the top, the
shaman priest would go to the top in
Mesopotamia. And at the top in an
altered state, they would make contact
with dead people who had been deified in
the afterlife.
Oh, wow.
This is the beginning of God and goddess
worship.
And it started at the top of a ziggurat.
And when God tells us who mystery
Babylon is in Revelation for the first
time, now I understand God used that
symbol of of the Tower of Babel. Wow.
Mystery Babylon is the mystery of you
are God and through altered states, you
will confirm it. This is this is what's
making nations drunk with some false
wine, some other doctrines, right? That
are not from Jesus Christ because they
say he's not a person. Jesus of Nazareth
was a way shower. He came to show us how
to tap into our own divinity.
Mhm. That's what they teach if you
listen long enough.
Sure. And that's the only way they can
join hands with these other religions in
the center that you saw. Does that make
sense?
And so the question is who is Jesus at
the end of the day? Who is he? Is he who
he claimed to be
or
or not? And who is man? What is man?
What is his nature?
And so those two questions by God's
grace the viewers are going to see
how we show the evidence and I'll
I'll show you in the film a short
segment on the Dead Sea Scrolls. Okay.
Because there's so many people who have
criticized the Bible, particularly the
Book of Daniel,
for thousands of years saying that what
Daniel wrote was written after the after
the events occurred.
So, the the dream that Nebuchadnezzar
had, his nightmare, right?
Of all of these rising and falling of
empires
was written after the fact. Couldn't
possibly No human brain could imagine or
guess those things. All have There's no
mathematical probability that you could
guess those things and have them come
out in exactly the order that you that
you guessed them. There's no probability
out there in the world. Also, he
predicted the exact year the Messiah,
the Christ, would come into the world.
And so we show that in the film through
the Dead Sea Scrolls that the Bible is
not just another book.
And so
again, we can't prove, but we can
provide evidence.
That Jesus
you know, so so
Daniel 2 shows the rise and fall of
empires all the way down to the 10 toes
in the feet.
And after the fall of Rome in 476,
there's a rise of a little horn called
the Antichrist and we identify
who that is and by the time you're done
listening to all of this stuff
and see how they've been promoting
mysticism, which is essentially a form
of spiritualism. Exactly right.
You see who the Antichrist really is
that's rising again
with a lot of power, but the only thing
in this vision that hasn't come out
exactly as it was predicted is this last
event.
The second coming of Jesus and are you
going to bet against the God of heaven?
Or are you going to surrender to his
word? And and that's kind of the call
that we want to give people.
Um today we're talking mostly about the
Christian side of this,
but it definitely has bridges and we'll
talk more in our next program about, you
know, how
these other traditions
through what through what the papacy is
doing,
um
they can find the true Jesus.
Because he really did come. Yeah. He
really was the Christ and we show the
evidence for all of the other world
views. And by the way, the the people
now that are that are that are
allegorizing and myth you know, at the
Bible being a myth of stories and not
true history, they'll see the evidence
also.
So, in this in the practice of
contemplative prayer, which has been
taught for centuries through the
Catholic Church that Stephanie was
practicing, uh why don't you tell them
about what happened to you with your
spiritual director, your chaplain,
in regards to
this um how this format led you into a
proposed kind of spiritualism?
Okay.
Well, I'd like to say first of all that
um because I believe that when you die,
like the Bible says, you are dead. David
sleeps, right? The dead know not
anything. So, that was my foundation.
And I'm grateful for that truth that I
had um hidden in my heart.
So,
it was a few years after my grandfather
had passed and I couldn't pray for him
that
my um spiritual director, who was the
hospital chaplain,
asked me to imagine a conversation with
my uh dead grandfather
about not being able to pray for him.
And see what he might have to say to me
today. He was trying to take me through
a process that would maybe relieve some
of my guilt about not being able to pray
for him.
But like I said, because of what I
believed, I told him I said, I I'm not
going to do that because that's that's
dangerous. I believe the dead are dead.
And that's another spirit that I would
be engaging with.
So,
this this is I I just feel as though God
really protected me. I know people who
have entered into these kinds of things
and have had demonic activity as a
result.
I even um
found out of someone who believes like I
do
and um was strong in her faith and began
meditating and was introduced to spirit
guides. That never happened to me.
Uh praise God.
But um
truth is a protectant and that's why we
need to be
searching the scriptures and not fall
for what I fell for.
Although I will tell you, many of the
viewers may be thinking I would never
fall for that.
Uh I will tell you that
it is in the churches and Yeah. it's
brought forward and not maybe
um a direct teaching, but an influence.
You can go on in in different um
organizations within our denomination
and find suggested reading list of these
mystics.
Um of things like The Shack, um Oh,
yeah. Yeah. So, and then they come and
they speak at your church and those
spirits that are influencing them,
we don't need to sit under their
teachings. Mhm. That is an opening.
So, and then there's a a book um called
Practicing the Presence
that is spiritual formation was part of
my curriculum. It's by Brennan Manning
and that's that's been brought forward
at a prophecy seminar.
So, we can't look to leaders, we can't
look to
author, by the way. Mhm. Yes. Well,
we're calling them out of Catholicism.
There's this mixed messages.
Are there any specific authors that you
would say stay away from?
I'm going to tell you honestly, my
library has become so thinned over the
years. It's I stick stick with the Bible
and probably the King James version.
Uh spirit of prophecy.
Uh a woman called Ellen White. I believe
she was very much um a prophet. Mhm.
And then I read Roger Morneau books. Uh
they are very helpful to my prayer life
and encouraging.
Um
It's very few very few things that I
read outside of those. By the way, I'm
glad you brought up Ellen White. There
there are
in several places in the book of Acts
the same word that they use for trance
or ecstasy which is the Greek word
translated ecstasy which is out of mind
or beside yourself.
That word shows up as trance in the book
of Acts three times. Peter and Paul both
are talking about being in prayer and
then falling into trance.
And when you read the context again it's
important to not just pick out verses
like they do but read the whole chapter.
Read chapters so that you can pray about
the context of what the Lord is teaching
through this story of the early church.
Why is the word trance in here and I
prayed a long time cuz it kind of shook
me.
So how do we defend this if it's in the
early church? Because why? Because I
assumed that a trance state was
inherently evil.
But if it's here it must mean that it's
not in and of itself inherently evil.
It's just a state that sometimes God
chooses to take over a person's
faculties when he has a special
visionary message through a vision or a
dream that he wants to give someone
while they're in their waking state.
And so this was very freeing for me and
exciting for me to see that it really is
a matter of possession.
Because the Holy Spirit came over them
while they were praying a biblical
prayer by the way in faith in Jesus.
What what what spiritual formation
teaches you
if you listen long enough is that it
doesn't matter what word you use. It
doesn't matter what you actually what
your dogma what your religion is.
You can all practice
this peaceful
practice.
So so the invitation is a wide road
religion through mysticism but the
biblical kind of prayer is
where the spirit is allowed to come in
and take over someone's conscious state
is someone who's actually praying like
Jesus did.
To a father who is a person not non-dual
not an impersonal God but but a friend
someone who knows you and that you know.
You don't die over a theory. Most of the
disciples were martyrs at the end
because they knew
that what they were
teaching was true right?
So the idea of trance
for people who are you know because I
knew the enemy would bring up the devil
would bring up oh but it's in the Bible.
So it must be copacetic for everyone to
practice this. It's how do you go there?
It's God that comes and transcends into
your mind in the Bible.
God is transcendent. We are not.
They're teaching that you can transcend
your conscious mind and go into a
timeless realm which quantum physics has
proven.
Right? Science has proven there's a
realm outside of our time and space
history timeline
but that's where God lives. Humans can't
go there.
Does that make sense?
There's a trance in the Bible and I'm
just like wow God this is a way to
actually show the evidence that we have
to know
God and worship Jesus in order to
receive the counselor the helper the
holy one and only Holy Spirit helper.
Does that make Does that make sense? I
think so yeah. For some reason my every
time you say trance my my brain goes to
music.
And so it's it's hard for me to
Think altered state cuz you were asking
at the very beginning what does it mean
what is what happens there? What do you
experience in that place?
As she was saying some people see what
they believe or ascended masters or
spirit guides.
See that's the whole thing the fallen
angels can masquerade in that state
based on what your belief system is.
That's why all of this has been
compartmentalized through thousands of
years.
They don't care what you believe
consciously if they can just get you to
practice to surrender your conscious
mind to a hypnotic state. That's what it
is.
In any religion and so that's kind of
what you went through through this whole
documentary it's showing that any
religion it's very similar in
just different terminology or
definitions.
the practices take you to the same place
including psychedelic drugs which you
saw in the trailer. We have a whole
segment a section in the film so that
people see this altered state can you
can you can do it through chanting you
can do it through dances you can do it
through mantras and meditation like she
did. You could psychedelic drugs is like
on steroids and now the federal
government is investing in it.
They're giving money to very reputable
hospitals like Johns Hopkins
who is now researching psilocybin in
their hospitals. And why is it? Because
people are starting to see and we'll
talk more about this in the next program
addictions anxiety depression and PTSD
are being healed by a plant.
And we'll talk more about how the devil
is using these plants next time.
Isn't it interesting? I read this
morning
when Jesus was on the cross
he was given vinegar right with
with guile right? Guile?
I looked it up anyway and he
Mix of gall yes thank you.
And when I looked it up it was basically
painkillers and he refused it. Whatever
state he was in he was dying. He was in
pain and he refused it. And here we are
as a society chasing this.
There is a true kind of prayer
and Roger Morneau lived it.
And
there's a quote in the film.
If we want power from on high in praying
for oneself or for others we must go
where the power is to be found.
Intercessory prayer you never hear about
it in this set of practices that in this
world
this alternative type of prayer to what
they believe is God.
Very few people actually have miracles
happening for other people. They're not
praying for other people and is not Is
it not true
that people who get involved in these
practices actually stop praying regular
prayers. See Christians start
by continuing their regular mental
prayers to to Jesus to God biblical
prayers. And it drops off.
Eventually it drops off. It didn't drop
off for me that was a protectant but for
most people it does. Yeah.
Yeah.
So do the prayers become very
self-focused?
No I would pray through the sanctuary.
You know the divine way
Before you would meditate. Yes yes and
see I put I put the silence into yield
so I would I would you know
praise repent ask you know and intercede
as well and then yield. What is what
does the God wants to say to me now? And
I would give him his his space. You know
let him speak.
Is Y E A L an acronym? What it was it
yield? Praise repent ask yield. Oh
yield's the last one.
And then pray through the sanctuary you
know enter his courts with praise and
you know thanksgiving.
And and go through and walk through that
so
um
I was very
biblical in my prayers.
But it was the readings. I was reading
in my Bible I was reading spirit of
prophecy
but I started reading things like this.
And it became very beautiful to me and
suddenly
the spirit of prophecy was very not so I
just quit reading that. I kept reading
my Bible praise God
but these books kind of took over
especially when I was in the curriculum.
They actually make the statement Thomas
Merton who's famous one of the famous
contemplatives of the 20th century
Thomas Merton wrote this book
contemplative prayer or contemplative
prayer
and he says the purpose of
Bible reading and mental prayers is to
prepare your faculties for the
supernatural.
In other words the end game it's a means
to an end and the end is that altered
state union with God. And their version
of reading the Bible was different.
It appears biblical but it's called
lectio divina divine reading sacred
reading. So it encourages you to read a
paragraph or two
and then out loud and then reread it
emphasizing different words and then
reread it again and
were there
a couple of words or was there a word
that kind of connected with you kind of
popped up was meaningful? Then you take
that word into your contemplative prayer
and see what God has to say to it.
We're supposed to study line upon line
precept upon precept. We don't extract
and then see what you know God has to
say. We need context. Yes and that
and and that actually ties in
that context and they lose truth. Right.
No I mean that ties right into
experience over
experience is the greatest authority
they say over a written word. In the end
the written word is only relevant and
and authoritative if it leads you to a
greater realization of who you are.
Or who God is for me it was who God is
but you know what he had to say to me
about that yeah what he had to say to me
about that and contemplative prayer
could have overridden what the Bible
said cuz that was then, this is now.
Exactly. And that's what we're seeing
today. It's a dynamic It's a dynamic
thing rather than an ancient book that
is always true.
It's a dynamic thing that becomes
relative and it's all based on what you
experience in this altered state. Mhm.
Fascinating. Fascinating. Um
So, um
tell people where they can find your
your soon-coming out documentary cuz
that's not out yet, but um you're you're
working on it and it looks already
fascinating.
Are you going to be Is it going to be
available on
uh local sources? Yeah, we'll we'll be
relea- we'll be releasing it most likely
on our YouTube channel. So, people can
come to Life Streams Media on our on
YouTube and find our channel there.
Um we'll also be doing some movie
extras. This is such a huge universe of
material.
Um it's by far the longest film that
I've ever worked on before and
you know, Stephanie's story started with
her journey in spiritual formation,
which is the Christian curriculum for
what we've been talking about, but it
really became a the whole world became
part of it. And uh and that's just been
a huge blessing. Um so, yes, it's it's
too important of a program to try to
sell or to try to you know, release like
we've done our previous titles. So, we
want to get it out there as quickly as
we can and I think YouTube for now is a
platform that still allows people to
speak what they believe.
Um and so, we'll we'll put it out there
as soon as we can.
And it's related to our previous two
projects, Beware of Angels and Charmed
by Darkness, which which the viewers can
watch there if you haven't seen them
yet.
Um they're on our YouTube channel.
They're free. Very good. Awesome.
Fantastic. Well, thank you, Stephanie
and Chris for joining us today. We
appreciate what you've shared and we
thank you for watching and joining us
for today's program. Make sure you like,
comment, and subscribe. Uh tell us what
you thought of this and if you've had
any experience like Stephanie's had,
we'd like to know about that. Also, uh
don't forget that we're on Patreon. You
can donate there and get some extra
features or on our website
littlelightstudios.tv
and uh we have merch, too.
lightware.shop if you want to catch some
designs, popular designs like we have
uh that we're wearing. So, thank you for
joining us and tune in again next week.
We'll see you then. Bye.
There has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world. And in
1999, a movie titled The Matrix hit the
world stage.
These stories are often told and seen
over and over again. Is it simply just
to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it?